The hot water of Kula is [ __ ]
Bakamon Your pronunciation is too accurate
You have talent, so if you can't adjust the system,
you'll die by suicide You're so
cute
Magic is a scary thing I wonder why words
have such power
Maybe through it
When we see a wooden four-legged round chair,
no matter what color it is or what wood it's
made of, we don't recognize that it's one round piece at the beginning of the four.
But I don't even think of it as a desk I
classify it by labeling it with the word "chair" In other words, it's
words that decide how the world should be
It's not possible to
say words side by side That's the kind of thing
that fluctuates in words Human beings use the same words
Strictly speaking, the conclusion is that it's better to say it twice.
I'm
sorry I didn't even use magic How?  But I can solve
it Buy the right tools Start up and rape the floor The
side is as important as the demon king
Ah ah ah I can even stroke the current issue ah
ah I want to count the load I can do with my heart
Untyler
[music]